[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui a résonné d'un bout à l'autre du
pays la semaine dernière mais qui sait
calmé depuis vendredi une pause pour
laisser toute la place au négociation
Ottawa indiqué hier que sa dernière
offre était finale alors à quoi doit-on
s'attendre à partir de maintenant voyons
voir ce qu'on pense mes collaborateurs
avec est absent cette semaine c'est Hugo
la vallée notre analyse à Québec est
avec nous à ses côtés Chantal Hébert
chronicard au Toronto Star et au
magazine L'actualité Michel coj qui est
analyse politique à la presse et la
Radio-Canada bon dimanche à vous trois
bonjour bonjour qu'est-ce que ça vous
dit chante là il y a personne qui parle
ni du côté du gouvernement ni du côté du
syndicat tout le monde est assis à la
table le gouvernement dit offre final
qu'est-ce qu'on comprend de ce qui est
en train de se produire
de la première chose qu'on comprend
c'est que les négociations continuent ce
qui explique le silence radio des deux
côtés parce que quand ça avance
généralement on n'entend rien et quand
ça va mal on entend le genre de choses
qu'on a entendu un peu cette semaine la
présence du conseil de ce que ça va être
incompétente du syndicat Justin Trudeau
qui laisse entendre qu'il faut faire des
demandes raisonnables cela dit on
s'entend quand le gouvernement ou la
partie patronale parle d'une offre en
disant elle est finale ce que ça veut
dire politiquement c'est que si ça
n'aboutit pas à une entente la prochaine
étape c'est forcément juste un Trudeau
qui doit trouver un allié pour faire une
loi de retour au travail
parce que on fait pas des offres finales
c'est mon dernier mot c'est censé être
le dernier on peut pas dire c'est mon
dernier mot quatre fois alors
ça parle sous sa case c'est à peu près
ce qui est résumé ce qui se passe en
dans le moment est-ce que
évidemment ça nous amène à l'autre
grande question Michel une loi spéciale
monsieur Trudeau à 25 commun puis avec
qui peut jouer la sur le parquet de la
Chambre des communes si on en arrive là
évidemment on n'est pas rendu là le ciel
en arrive là est important parce que si
ces gens-là se parlent encore à l'heure
où il alors qu'il est c'est que il y a
quelque chose qui progresse alors moi je
suis sûr que le gouvernement ne veut pas
aller à l'ouest spécial ça serait
l'obliger à faire un entente soyons
clair avec la moyenne je posture que
c'est ça il y a pas d'autres partenaires
il y a pas d'autres personnel le bloc a
dit très clairement qu'il ne voteront
pas pour une loi de votre travail puis
une on sait bien qu'il ne le prend
pas alors ça laisse pas beaucoup de
marches de manœuvre ça donc ce qui fait
que les chanteurs de la raison quand on
dit qu'on fait une offre finale on a à
peu près la marge de manœuvre qu'on a
quand on est dans une organisation de
force on peut bouger un petit peu mais
pas beaucoup parce que sinon ça veut
plus rien dire alors la bonne nouvelle
ce qui se passe la moins bonne nouvelle
c'est que si il ne se parle plus
monsieur Trudeau va être obligé de
trouver un point un morceau d'entente
avec Monsieur poignet ça sera pas un
exercice qui va aimer faire on en parle
avec Luc Burton ne peut plus tôt c'est
pas ça se dessine pas comme un exercice
simple Hugo on garde on garde un œil sur
ses négociations là chez vous parce que
ça négocier aussi dans ce secteur public
à Québec il y en a qui doivent prendre
des notes
absolument évidemment on en est pas
exactement la même étape du processus
les parties ont encore ont pas encore
acquis le droit de grève mais c'est
certain qu'il va avoir un impact puis
déjà cette offre le pas la finale parce
qu'on en a pas les détails mais l'offre
précédente qui avait été rendu public
c'était quoi 9 % du gouvernement sur 3
ans c'est ça à Québec on a 9 % mais sur
5 ans alors déjà il y a un écart
important déjà qui avait précédemment
aussi en écart c'est pas un secret entre
la fonction publique fédéral et la
fonction publique québécoise notre
personne qui doit suivre ça de près
aussi c'est le gouverneur de la Banque
du Canada qui a quelques semaines à
peine mettait en garde contre des
augmentations de salaire trop importante
en disant que c'était une préoccupation
pour lui que c'était pas compatible avec
un recul évidemment de l'inflation et
puis aussi l'effet d'entraînement que ça
peut avoir non seulement sur les
gouvernements dans les provinces mais
aussi sur le secteur privé bien sûr
souvent c'est un peu la locomotive ce
qui est négocie dans le secteur public
sans compter par exemple de ces demandes
sur le télétravail ça c'est intéressant
est-ce que ça peut créer un précédent
forcer la main de certains employeurs
qui sont peut-être un peu plus
réfractaires enfin pas nécessairement ça
que Monsieur Trudeau va avoir en tête là
on a l'impression qu'il veut régler ça
au plus vite sans nécessairement tenir
compte d'éventuelles impacts sur le
secteur privé mais c'est certain que
c'est suivi près puis que ça fait partie
de l'équation Chantal est-ce que oui
vous allez dire
ce que Justin Trudeau doit vouloir
politiquement c'est que personne dise
qui a acheté la tête avec les effets
dont on vient de parler donc il y a
besoin quelque part de tenir son bout
quand sa présidente du Conseil du Trésor
disait
notre offre salariale mais j'ai encore
un petit peu de marge de manœuvre on
s'entend si c'est pas aller dans la
marge faire un peu de ce qu'une offre
salariale donnerait mais au niveau du du
milieu du travail c'est quand même
intéressant de voir parce qu'on on est
rendu là à codifier le télétravail c'est
pas quelque chose qui va disparaître en
même temps que la pandémie et c'est
quand même intéressant de voir comment
un employeur de l'envergure du
gouvernement du Canada va arriver à
codifier ou pas le télétravail qui
devient de plus en plus une exigence de
beaucoup de gens quand ils se cherchent
un emploi au moment où ils ont le gros
bout du bâton
parce que pénurie de travailleurs et là
les syndiqués disent c'est fait un peu
de façon arbitraire par les cadres dans
les différents mystères on voudrait on
voudrait avoir un modèle Michel il y en
a plusieurs qui ont regardé ça les
conservateurs sont très critiques
évidemment tout comme le NPD de la façon
dont les libérons on gérer sa
négociations là comment qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de la façon dont Monsieur
Trudeau gérer les négociations avec les
secteurs publics jusqu'ici
carrément impliqué dans les négociation
ce qui est grave rarement une bonne idée
sauf à la toute fin évidemment parce que
la toute fin il faut remonter jusqu'au
premier ministre alors il a pas été très
impliqué mais en même temps c'est comme
ça qu'on doit négocier pour laisser la
table
exister à boire les discussions qui se
passent à table de négociation et tout
ça sauf que évidemment quand on négocie
avec l'État ce serait la même chose à
Québec dans quelques mois
la menace de loi spéciale est toujours
là même si on a on ne mentionne pas le
mot comme Voldemort un moment donné
c'est clair que elle est là tout le
monde le sait ça fait partie de la
négociation ça aussi alors moi je trouve
que ce Trudeau avait pas d'intérêt à
s'impliquer personnellement trop fort
dans une négociation comme cela puis
c'est rare qu'un premier ministre gagne
quelque chose quand il le fait
effectivement on va mettre un terme à
cette à cette passion là de discussion
sur l'analogie avec Harry Potter et on
va passer
je vais vous faire entendre un extrait
de monsieur Legault cette semaine puis
on va revenir sur un autre sujet qui a
retenu beaucoup d'attention actuellement
on exclut pas que ça soit un métro que
ça soit un tramway que ça soit un REM
comme à Montréal donc faut évidemment
regarder quelle sorte de transport
collectif il y aura dans le tunnel avant
d'être capable de vous donner une
estimée
bon là on parlait du troisième hier le
transport en commun j'ai eu l'impression
quand j'écoutais monsieur Legault cette
semaine de réentendre monsieur Legault
il y a quelques années pas trop de
détails pas de coup est-ce qu'on est en
train de rejouer un peu dans le même
film parce que le troisième lien pour le
transport en commun il va se faire qui
dit monsieur Legault mais il y a pas
beaucoup plus de détails que ça
ouais effectivement c'est assez
saisissant de voir qu'on s'apprête à
répéter un peu le même scénario parce
que ça c'est ça qui est nuit beaucoup à
la carte ces deux dernières semaines on
a vu qu'on avait fait des promesses on
s'était beaucoup engagés alors qu'on
n'avait pas de données sur la chalandage
potentielle pas de données précis sur
les coups du premier de la première
version du troisième lien en version
transport en commun et autoroute et là
on s'apprête à refaire la même chose ni
plus ni moins avec cette nouvelle
mouture entièrement dédiée aux
transports en commun on sait pas si le
gouvernement fédéral va s'impliquer
monsieur Legault lui-même admettant
commission parlementaire qu'on a pas de
détails sur le coup pas exactement de
détails non plus sur le tracé sur la
chalandage sur le mode de transport qui
va être retenu et pourtant ben ça pas
empêché plusieurs membres de son cocus
encore une fois de s'avancer Bernard
drinville pour pas le nommer qui dit
qu'il voudrait voir un chantier là d'ici
les prochaines élections de 2026 comme
si on n'avait pas vraiment retenu les
leçons de cet exercice là et c'est
d'autant plus curieux qu'on voit
justement à quel point ça a fait que la
crédibilité de Monsieur le logo là ces
dernières semaines depuis que l'annonce
a été faite l'impression que c'est comme
si le charme un peu avait été rompu
parce que monsieur Legault est en
position de force depuis quoi déjà 5 ans
c'est assez incroyable mais quand même
là on voit que ça a été beaucoup plus
difficile puis c'est certain que les
parties d'opposition vont pas lâcher le
morceau pour une fois qu'ils ont des
attaques qui portent et là bah on leur
fournit un peu des munitions justement
en ayant pas de détails à offrir pas
vraiment de précision mais en étant en
même temps ce terme sur la décision
c'est un peu curieux je vais aller vers
celui que
vos commentaires ont cité le plus de
réactions chez Michel vous avez acheté
de la tête à 3 ou 4 reprises on n'a pas
appris de nos erreurs c'est ça
je m'excuse de dire comme ça mais il y a
une des définitions de la folie qui est
de faire exactement les mêmes choses si
vous espérez un résultat différent et
comme je pense pas que au gouvernement
du Québec qui soit fou moi je pense que
qu'est-ce qu'on fait parfois quand on a
fait un gros mensonge on rétablit la
vérité par étape moi je pense que le
troisième lien est mort le tunnel
n'existera jamais mais là on maintient
description du tunnel qui va être
seulement pour le transport en commun y
compris en disant des choses qui ont pas
de bon sens est-ce que ça peut être un
thème ça c'est un très suspendu dans un
tunnel ça marche
un moment donné
assez peu de concret la réalité c'est
qu'on le voit c'est si on fait le tunnel
de l'autre côté du Saint-Laurent allez-y
il n'y a pas d'infrastructure de
transport en commun conséquente alors on
peut pas amener les gens la station
Libye et là c'est bon et c'est pour ça
que ça se fera pas à la fin mais les
gens n'arrivent sud de Québec vous avez
il y a eu des sondages cette semaine je
comprenne qui sont faits à chaud puis il
faut faire attention mais les gens
d'aller sud de Québec c'est le royaume
de l'auto-solo ce n'est pas un endroit
où le transport quand même marche très
bien alors il faut juste prendre la tête
faire ça elle va passer au lieu au
troisième lien par étape pour les
chantages
c'est que dans la phrase de Monsieur le
gars il y avait pas de tapis volant
montgolfière pas de de ballets
on est beaucoup néanmoins dans la c'est
magique et la pensée magique s'inclut le
financement
qui va venir du fédéral bon d'abord le
fédéral ne s'engage pas en l'absence
d'un vrai projet sur la table avec des
coûts des échéanciers mais deuxièmement
il y a quand même un ours là il va y
avoir des élections fédérales avant le
prochain rendez-vous québécois de 2026
peut-être que Justin Trudeau va être élu
peut-être pas et s'il n'est pas pierre
poignard lui dit j'en veux pas à moins
que un lien automobile ça prend des
voitures
lui ça lui prend des voitures on dirait
de qu'on est dans un magasin de jouets
puis mon est en train de mettre ce qui
voudrait je suis comme Michel j'ai
tendance à croire que le projet va
disparaître je pense qu'on l'avait dit
la semaine dernière ne serait-ce que
parce que il y a pas beaucoup de députés
qui vont vouloir faire campagne sur le
troisième lien transport en commun
seulement en 2026 chaque fois qu'ils
vont s'ouvrir la bouche ça va rappeler
un le commerce briser et deux le fait
que c'est pas vraiment ça que les gens
de la région
un peu plus de 2 minutes à Hugo comment
on fait comment Monsieur le groupe
peut-il mettre le couvercle sur cette
marmite là parce que ça deux semaines
que ça leur entre le 3e bien comment on
fait pour changer de chapitre bah on a
de voir son plan de communication
effectivement parce que ça le poursuit
et là cette semaine bah il y a eu cette
tentative un peu de
si on veut d'apaiser le caucus là
évidemment dans un premier temps on
avait permis à chacun d'étaler sur la
place publique ses émotions là cette
semaine bon notre tenue le caucus
spécial officiellement pour écouter les
députés on a l'impression déjà que c'est
une première étape non seulement pour
écouter mais aussi pour dire bon on va
mettre fin là aux émotions qui
s'expriment de part et d'autre c'est de
resserrer les rangs ça c'est la première
étape deuxième étape ce serait
probablement de faire diversion trouver
un autre sujet c'est là où Monsieur Lego
lui-même se nuit en alimentant justement
avec cette fiction dont on parlait
Michel et Chantal sur la nouvelle
mouture du troisième bien ben là il
donne des prises à l'opposition qui
évidemment
s'en privera pas parce qu'en fait ils
ont le sentiment de trouver quelque
chose qui peut vraiment nuire au
gouvernement puis la meilleure preuve de
ça c'est probablement la réaction de
Monsieur Lego lui-même qui a pas eu des
réponses toujours très élégantes cette
semaine on le sentait très irrité en
chambre et bien évidemment quand on voit
ça du côté de l'opposition poursuit dans
la même version est-ce que Chantal c'est
ça l'erreur monsieur LEGO est en train
de donner l'excision d'un truc qui lui
pose des problèmes c'est ça
j'avoue que il y avait des modèles de
promesse rompus je vous ramène m'adapter
c'est agent chrétien la première chose
qu'on avait fait c'est s'excuser la
deuxième c'est passé à d'autres choses
c'était pas de dire qu'on va trouver un
autre plan pour trouver
non et ça a réglé le problème beaucoup
plus rapidement à terme normalement la
colère va s'apaiser mais entre temps le
problème c'est que c'est en train de
devenir un problème de crédibilité
est-ce que vous avez confiance en la
paroi de François Legault c'est soit
c'est ça la vraie question qui
reste pas sans réponse mais avec une
réponse plus négative que deux semaines
et ça c'est c'est
un immense désavantage pour un
gouvernement c'est tout le temps qui
nous reste malheureusement on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler du troisième
lien probablement parce que en tout cas
techniquement c'est encore une promesse
de monsieur Legault cette idée de faire
un troisième lien pour le transport en
commun Hugo Chantal Michel merci d'avoir
été là